hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes as per the usual I'm here to
recap the most ravishing ideas from
around wired because sunday was Easter
and because this is my show and I'll do
whatever I want we're talking about the
plagues of Egypt you may remember these
from the Bible or from the animated film
that paired large-scale death with
musical numbers as God intended our
April issue took a look at how studying
swarms of locusts could help us fight
cancer or predict the future or destroy
a bunch of cauliflower which everybody
agrees tastes super gross so locusts
were one of ten plagues gifted unto
Egypt by God who wanted to set the
Israelites free and destroy it as much
cauliflower as possible which you
regretted ever inventing on account of
its taste and stupid texture other
weapons in God's war against a key
vegetables included introducing
perpetual darkness slaughtering
firstborns turn the Nile into blood or
maybe kool-aid raining down fire inhale
and introducing boils disease lice flies
and frogs and some scientists believe
these place might have actually struck
Egypt over 3,000 years ago and it was Al
Gore and his darn climate change and the
liberal media and the gay marriage that
started it all you see a sudden dry
period is believed to have shriveled up
the Nile leading to an explosion of a
toxic cyanobacteria called burgundy
blood algae which proliferate and
slow-moving water and smells like scotch
this would have forced the frogs to
venture inland in a sort of reversed
Frogger except no car and no pavement I
guess and probably no highscores the
frogs inevitable demise meant insects
like flies went on haunted there weren't
any bug zappers back then and praying to
God for help certainly wouldn't have
done it good so the swarm multiplied and
brought with it the plagues of diseases
and as for the deaths of the first ones
it's theater like this may have been due
to a fungus hiding in the grain supply
first four males were given privileged
access to food and Bennifer would have
been the first to fall ill to top it all
off around this time a massive volcanic
eruption blue part what is now the Greek
island of Santorini creating some nice
cliff face property to one day
overcharged tourists to drink wine on
the resulting
ash cloud reached Egypt darken the skies
and perhaps interacting with weather
systems to produce hail which Egyptians
might have called golf ball sized or
baseball sized if they have been bro
enough to invent such sports this sudden
moisture would have brought about the
plague of locusts which prefer such
conditions for breeding so now you're
thinking about locust breeding and now
you're watching it and for that i only
have apologized because this is my show
and I can do whatever I want
you